لليوم الحادي عشر تواليا خرج الفرنسيون
للشوارع احتجاجا على اصلاح نظام التقاعدي
في البلاد اندلعت اشتباكات بين الشرطه
الفرنسيه والمتظاهرين كما نرى الرافدين
لقانون تمديد سنه تقاعد في عدد من المدن
الفرنسيه في العاصمه باريس عطل المتظاهرون
حركه الطريق واشعلوا النيران في بعض
الشوارع والمطاعم كما نرى فيما اطلقت
الشرطه الغاز المسيل للدموع لتفريقهم
احتجاجات اليوم تاتي بعد يوم من فشل
اجتماع رئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيث بورن مع قاده النقابات وقبل
انطلاق احتجاجات الخميس توقعت الشرطه خروج
ما يتراوح بين
6800,000 شخص في مختلف المدن الفرنسيه مع
الاشاره الى مشاركه نحو 1000 شخص قد
يشكلون خطرا في العاصمه ورغم الرفض الشعبي
لمشروعي رفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
الا انه
يمضي على طريق التطبيق بعدما تم اقراره في
الشهر الماضي في العشرين تحديدا من الشهر
الماضي واختارت الحكومه في نهايه المطاف
تمرير مشروع القانون من دون تصويت في
البرلمان بينما لم تتراجع المعارضه وايضا
النقابات التي تطالب بسحبه
[تصفيق]